a Mentalist is there's different labels
to a Mentalist but the label that I like
for Mentalist is that's it's someone who
invokes mystery there are some
mentalists who manipulate people's
thoughts and have the ability to
hypnotize people and I like to create
mystery and invoke that in people the
mystic element is that the mystic
represents seeking truth so I'm a seeker
of truth and I like to take people along
with me through the entertainment to
explore truth
a Mentalist is someone who relies more
on abilities of the mind whether it be
the reading other people body language
psychology influencing their thinking or
some people would say even psychic
abilities and abilities to predict the
future whereas a magician will use more
props and sleight of hand that's the
distinction
I had a psychic experience early on when
I was in high school and I had a few
different ones but there was one in
particular that really struck me so that
intrigued me and I started to enquire
and look at my experience and the
experiment with it there was no training
but it it's more you experiment with
different ways of doing things and you
just see if it works and most of the
time it doesn't work but then you just
keep experimenting and when it works it
often catches you by surprise but then
you reflect back and you go okay what
was it that happened that it actually
worked
there was a German Mentalist named Ted
Leslie who in the early day when I was
just starting out I met him through my
travels and he told me something really
interesting that intrigued me and that
impacted me quite a bit
he said that 99% of your success as a
Mentalist has to do with your how you
are rather than what you do and I was
more leaning towards doing incredible
things but that impacted me quite a bit
he's no longer alive but he was he was
really onto something there
well I think it brings the inner and the
outer together because I think when you
when when one starts in performance you
you tend to relate to that you're
putting something out you know that it's
either a skill that you're putting out
or a knowledge or an ability that you're
putting out but then you realize that
actually what you're really putting out
is yourself and you're also putting out
a skill in the performance but it's a
vehicle to put yourself out and so I
learned that early on because when I
started performing I was actually
performing on the streets in Tel Aviv
and so there I had to put myself into it
because otherwise I wouldn't get much
response you know if I was just putting
out something and and my tendency was
has been to to just play it safe and not
to put myself out but to put out
something cool or fancy or impressive
and then I think what I've learned is
that you know the it's you know you you
have an opportunity to put yourself out
and and since who we are has boundless
depth then you can always go deeper in
putting putting out who you are because
there's always more you know it's not
just you know it's not just
two-dimensional you're not just someone
who enjoys messing with people's minds
there's more depth to it than that and
and part of it is sometimes you just
Intuit that and then you have to dig
deeper to find out what that actually
means